this video is sponsored by skillshare hi
everybody welcome back to the main
carrying things Cinematic Universe I
want to continue to share more book
recommendations on this channel because
people have reached out to me and said
hey I really appreciate reading these
things and then you let me know that you
read it and I'm like wow I'm
I'm an influencer also the Sun is going
down which means that I have limited
time to talk about these books so for no
particular reason and in no particular
order here's a bunch of books that I
like that I think you should read
Flannery O'Connor this seems kind of
like a no-brainer I don't know why I
haven't really talked much about
Flannery O'Connor on the channel one of
the strangest and most interesting
writers I've ever encountered and she
wrote mostly short stories you know the
kind of Southern Gothic genre but
there's a lot of humor and darkness
mixed and Flannery O'Connor's work that
I love the violent buried away and wise
blood are two of her novels that she
wrote and wise blood was turned into an
excellent John Houston movie obviously a
Good Man is Hard to Find is one of the
standouts but I also love the life you
save may be your own read Flannery
O'Connor just do it do you like crime I
I'm not a fan of of doing it I like to
read about it so Double Indemnity by
James M Kane was turned into an
excellent Billy Wilder movie in the 40s
really tough cynical Edge to it and Kane
sort of mastered the voice of tough uh
hardened criminals that we've come to
expect from um Noir it's a really
riveting book with a kind of bizarre
ending that makes you question the
authenticity of our narrator another
Cane wreck that I love is The Postman
Always Rings Twice super short both of
these books are really short the plot
against America by Philip Roth Roth is a
hugely prolific and fascinating writer
controversial in many ways it's
basically alternate history but told in
a very um like family setting uh it's a
look at what may have happened if
Roosevelt didn't win let's say his third
term in office essentially it boils down
to the rise in anti-Semitism which hey
very relevant to today so you know very
realistic and just a great Insight so
it's a book I really like Movable Feast
by Ernest Hemingway this is technically
non-fiction but based on some stuff I've
read it a lot of it could be fictional
basically Hemingway is recounting his
years in Paris in the 20s and what it
was like being a writer then in his
day-to-day existence but also unique
stories not a very flattering portrait
of F Scott Fitzgerald at Hemingway
paints so I take it more as fiction as a
kind of like romanticized vision of
Hemingway writing about his younger days
in Paris you know it just has that
really beautiful full vibrant Pros it
just brings you to a specific place it
is kind of like a comfort book of mine
that I like to just kind of get immersed
in the pages no strong forward story
momentum in this it's just more of a you
know a collection of situations a
collection of of feelings I love this
book if I mean you like Hemingway and
you haven't read this you know obviously
give it a shot but before our next book
a word from our sponsor skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skillshare look it's no
surprise I'm a certified skillshare fan
I have been one of the most delightful
and consistent sponsorships I've worked
with I've talked in the past about the
writers toolkit six steps to a
successful riding habit by Simon van boy
I think it's a great practical course on
how to you know deep in and get a better
consistent writing habit but I've really
been getting into graphic design lately
and I thought that graphic design Basics
core principles for visual design by
Ellen Lupton was a fantastic and a
really great introductory course into
graphic design a subject that I know so
little about it is embarrassing you can
watch than bite size videos or watch the
full course it's curated specifically
for learning meaning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in Spanish
French Portuguese and German the first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one month go check it out learn
something new skillshare back to the
video the next book I want to recommend
is the Hamlet by William Faulkner a lot
of you know I'm a huge fan of William
Faulkner even to a point of being very
pretentious about it but I just uh love
Faulkner's Pros I think that he doesn't
get enough credit for how funny he is
and the mixture of darkness and comedy
very reminiscent of you know Flannery
O'Connor of course they're writing in
similar regions you know in the Southern
United States so this book is about the
rise of a mysterious individual in many
ways just the embodiment of capitalism
just pure greed phlegm Snopes this is
the first in a trilogy but I do think
that this is the strongest book in that
trilogy funny but also darkest and most
Twisted stories it feels more like a
collection of short stories in a lot of
way but don't let that remove the
urgency from this book because it feels
very urgent there's there's a lot of
momentous stuff occurring and in very
epic Mythic stuff you know Faulkner
writes like in a Mythic way beautiful
writing and I do think that this is a
good entryway into Faulkner because he
isn't on his crazy out there Absalom
Absalom writing you know 100 word
sentences you know every page this is a
little more reined in check out the
Hamlet on writing by Stephen the king is
probably the best book about writing
I've ever read I love Lawrence Block's
books on writing but Stephen King has a
wonderful way with describing the simple
stuff but also hinting at the larger
more important things that you know it
takes to become a working writer an
incredibly readable book even though it
contains grammar about characters about
paragraph structure but he himself is
not really able to dive completely into
what makes it work for him because he's
very uh intuitive writer so there's kind
of this war going on between these are
the fundamentals but there's also a
little magic there going on it is a
really great insight even if you aren't
a writer yourself I think that it's a
great look into the life of just one of
the most important creative people of
the 20th century arguably so the Great
Bridge is a very long non-fiction book
about bridges uh the other day someone
asked me uh if I read any nonfiction and
I thought yeah I do but I haven't in a
while I do like long books that dive
into like one topic I read a book about
Nixon a while ago for some reason it was
really interesting the Great Bridge is
David McCullough everyone's dad's
favorite historian interesting look at
the building of the Brooklyn Bridge in
the 1800s the discovery of of the bends
and how that was a huge very difficult
challenge in building this bridge labor
activity going on what New York politics
was like at the time I mean it covers
every facet of the people on the the
board of Executives you know the people
who made this thing happen how it took
so long it was just a gargantuan
undertaking and and kind of we uh don't
really acknowledge the massive massive
feet it was for its time it's very good
garbage by AR Ammons is a book about or
sorry it's a poem about garbage I don't
talk about poetry enough but this is my
one of my volumes of AR Eminence poetry
I love aramins I've I particularly like
his longer poems I love tape for the
turn of the year and especially garbage
garbage was one of his later long poems
it is kind of a rumination you kind of
just go on his journey through these
subjects and there are beautiful
insights very striking lines and it is
it is a trip it's a journey it's it's
less about the message than it is the
process and if there's any subject
that's perfect for our modern times to
talk about it you know let's let's talk
about the garbage the detritus that
which is discarded and discardible since
everything in our current culture feels
so discardable garbage 100 Years of
Solitude how have I not talked about
this book yet this is one of my favorite
books of all time it is a masterpiece I
mean it is the defining magical realist
book so many people have talked about
this book and people will talk about
this book forever Gabriel Garcia Marquez
just an incredible writer wrote one of
my favorite short stories ever written
the handsomest round man in the world
please read it I'm sure you could find
it free somewhere online you know it was
written in Spanish but thank God for
this translator for I mean it's just a
beautiful translation of this book
Gregory rabasso that's the translator a
beautiful dark haunting magical lens
through which to see the Carnage that
occurred in Latin America through
imperialism confusing messy family
history coups with dictatorships with
you know the rise and fall of History
being scattered all over these Pages
just until the very you know haunting
final Pages it is it's amazing and I do
want to read it again it's been a while
the sun is really almost down what is it
fall or something final book I want to
recommend is Cannery Row by John
Steinbeck this is a very simple story
about town that is basically Monterey in
California it is just about the people
living in the town it's it's very Slice
of Life but very touching you fall in
love with these characters I mean
Steinbeck was very much in the school of
uh you know Hemingway so while Steinbeck
you know famously wrote very socially
provocative novels uh The Grapes of
Wrath uh in dubious battle I don't know
it's a comfort book for me it's it
really is and uh let me know what I
think I would enjoy to read because I am
I'm always looking out for new stuff to
read so anyways that was the man
carrying thing book club thank you for
watching and thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video all right
have a good one everyone bye-bye
[Music]